lizzo
just
attempted to normalize abortion at the
People's Choice Awards
I know
call abortion who was working to
normalize abortion increase awareness of
abortion pills and
move to work in support of the abortion
access in their communities make some
noise
yeah we still going yeah we're still
going kill all your babies
oh yeah we're gonna go and we're and
then she goes down the line with all the
other what causes and the abortion lady
she talked to holds up a sign and it
says abortion pills forever yeah pop
that poison pill and Murder Your
Precious Child wow and then the crowd is
just out there they're like wow give us
Barabbas wow yeah cause Paramus and you
look at the scene
and you think you know
it was ever thus
it was ever thus we are tempted to look
at these things and say wow oh man this
has never happened before maybe the
specific iterations of The Madness of
crowds has never happened before but
this sort of reaction
two wicked false evil things this has
happened this often happens okay
if you were to watch that clip with the
sound off those of you who are listening
in the car right now if you
go back you watch it you turn the sound
off
you could still tell not hearing a word
that they're saying that these people
are on the wrong side of things
you could tell because
no one there seems to be in control of
their passions
they just seem like a ravenous
competitive
monstrous sort of crowd
there's lizzo just screaming and kind of
gesticulating wildly everywhere she's
obviously not in control of a lot of her
life and then the Mad crowd like yes
give us the babies yeah give me so I
could kill the babies and then you've
got the woman she points to and she's
well he's shaking that sign yeah let's
keep you and and they're obviously not
not in control of themselves so it's
actually a kind of encouragement
when you look back and see how the truth
has been treated throughout history it
is an encouragement to those of us who
are living today and we say wow no one's
ever had it this bad well you know look
what they did to Socrates okay who said
a lot of true things look what they did
to Jesus who is the truth okay this is
this is what crowds do
this is often what political orders do
because the prince of this world is the
devil who is the father of Lies okay so
that that sort of thing is going to
happen we are going to have a tough slog
it doesn't matter though we should we
should take comfort we're in this Advent
season right now we should take comfort
because
uh our Lord has overcome the world okay
we know how the story ends the story
ends happily but there will be a lot of
tribulation in the meantime there will
be a lot of challenge in the meantime
it's okay that's a that's a a good thing
all right it's it's an honor to be born
into a time of great Challenge and a
Great Tribulation the way that we are
going to
have success the way we are going to
overcome these things is
valid to be sort of childlike gets back
to what John Kennedy's comedy routine
there it gets back to the the wisdom of
Norm Macdonald it gets back to how we
stand up to the people who run the
academic institutions and all the media
we just ask kind of simple questions we
say I know I just saw you I saw your
whole scientific presentation I I
listened to your whole lecture about how
12 year olds need to be indoctrinated
into weird sex toy stuff and how boys
are actually girls and how we need to
kill all the babies and how the Sun
monster is going to eat us all in five
years but I know I I just but
is that is that real doesn't make a
whole lot of sense to me I you know I
think I'm gonna stick with the good
old-fashioned way of doing things right
now head on over to goodranchers.com use
code Knowles a hard year on the economy
means that essential practical gifts are
going to be in high demand this year
give the most essential gift of all
America's best meat and seafood from
good Ranchers with discounts on orders
of five boxes or more you can save on
gifts for the whole family
when you give a box of good ranchers
you're giving them a true Steakhouse
experience with 100 American USDA prime
and upper Choice cuts of beef chicken
seafood other meat delivery companies
and even your local grocery stores
import lower Quality Meat from overseas
do not give your friends and family less
than America's best this year not sure
what to order good ranchers now offers
gift cards so you can let your friends
and family members choose for it
themselves or give the gift of a
subscription
and you can inflation proof someone's
meat budget go to goodranchers.com use
code Knowles kwles at checkout to get 35
off your gift that is goodranchers.com
code Knowles for 35 off good ranchers
American Meat delivered
there's a writer and producer
for Gray's Anatomy who's who's in the
midst of a big Scandal right now
uh this woman has just been exposed is
having made a whole bunch of claims
about her life that turned out not to be
true
so this woman
has claimed This Woman's name is Finch
Finch
forget I forget what her first name is
no it doesn't really matter she's a
writer producer I'm Gray's Anatomy very
popular show and
she had a real sob story she said that
she had cancer
very bad
and an abortion
that's that's very bad too and a kidney
loss oh that's very bad and then her
brother killed himself wow that's very
bad and then
she had to take a leave of absence do
you think man I mean I know when it
rains it pours but this lady she's like
Dr Doom over here everything just keeps
going wrong for her she takes a leave of
absence ultimately she resigns from the
show turns out it was all fake she just
made all of it up
she said quote when you get wrapped up
in a lie you forget who you told what
you said to this person and whether this
person knows that thing and that's the
world where you can get caught
she just kind of came clean in this long
interview with the ankler so I don't
need to worry about that now how did it
all start it started because she got a
knee injury it was a that was the real
part it wasn't that she got cancer and
an abortion and lost a kidney and her
brother killed himself the real issue is
she hurt her knee a little bit and then
she said instead of getting addicted to
medication
she became addicted to all the attention
that she was getting all the Care all
the pity and sympathy that she was
getting and so as she recovered she
started to lose that attention in that
sympathy and she was so desperate to get
it back that she made up all of these
problems
this all started to unravel when she met
this woman Jennifer Byer it turns out
this lady Finch is a lesbian and so she
meets this lady and then they have a
romantic relationship together and the
lady says hey hey man hey hey lady you
gotta you're lying you gotta come clean
about all of this and she does complain
so obviously look this this is a very
troubled woman she's got all sorts of
confusion in all parts of her life
but it's not just her
this is the whole culture
the whole culture
exalts victimhood we know that I'm not
saying anything you haven't heard before
victimhood carries currency in our
culture that is why we're told that
white people have privilege and black
people are oppressed and why why we have
so many instances of white women
pretending to be black
it doesn't let's just go with the
premise for a second that there is such
a thing as white privilege and there is
such a thing as black oppression in
America
just just go with them for a moment
well if that's all true then why is it
that the people who supposedly believe
that
often are white people who then pretend
to be black Rachel dollazole that NYU
Professor a number of other people in
these high profile cases
why is it that uh Jesse Smollett
pretends to be robbed by white
supremacists in Maga country with a
noose and a Subway sandwich
why is it that virtually every time you
see I hate hoax on campus you know
racial or sexual it it turns out to be
just that it turns out to be fake
whenever you see the n-word written on a
dorm room wall guess who wrote it 999
times out of a thousand it's going to be
the black student himself every time you
see a noose hanging on campus who put it
there every time you see a swastika who
put it it's always done by the alleged
victims
why
because victimhood has currency but why
does victimhood have currency that's the
question a lot of people won't answer
the reason that victimhood is carrying
currency right now is because
our culture
cannot attain excellence
I'm sure we could we're just not willing
to do the things that are required to
attain excellence and so
because we're in in a normal society the
way you get social currency is by doing
impressive things by doing by being
physically excellent intellectually
excellent achieving something in
business or politics
but today if you're physically really
strong and beautiful and fit that's
called tax toxic masculinity we got to
get rid of that's awful that's evil if
you're really really beautiful oh you're
just conforming to those evil
traditional social norms and Beauty
Norms if you build a big successful
business you're a greedy evil capitalist
you probably only got that by exploiting
people and this is just because
uh people are not inclined they're not
willing to put in the work they're not
really willing to accept the humility
that is required to attain excellence
and so a culture that refuses to attain
excellence
is going to be a culture that elevates
Frailty infirmity
victimhood that's what's happening
and so you're going to see a lot more of
it this confused lady on Gray's Anatomy
she's just
she is the tip of the iceberg okay the
rest of the show continues now you do
not want to miss it if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]